by the way guys just one other thing
about theme what do you want to say in
your story do you just want a house in
Malibu is that why you're writing your
television show because if that's the
only reason you're writing it maybe
you'll succeed but it won't be a very
strong story why is that what's the
truth about life you want to get across
in your story there is a truth about
life and breaking bad what do you want
to say about life this isn't just some
stupid exercise it's your passion
because remember theme is about the
truth you want to tell about life what
do you want to say what do you want to
say nothing we'll think about it
you do want to say something Vince
Gilligan is saying that power really
corrupts absolutely corrupts especially
weak people what's the theme in oranges
a new bot by the way a great show by
gingy cohan
what's the theme there what's the
problem in that show
it's that Piper doesn't have a strong
sense of herself that means she can go
with girls she can go with guys she can
betray them both she doesn't know who
she is you gotta know who you are that's
a great theme too in Sons of Anarchy
another fabulous show the hero wants or
add the writer the show Kurt Sutter
wants to tell us you're doomed if you
don't have a good mentor do you not have
a good mentor
have you not had a good mentor in your
life are your parents shitty a crappy
sorry if they're crappy you're in
trouble you better find a mentor that's
the whole reason Kurt Sutter wrote Sons
of Anarchy even if he tells it wasn't so
we need to understand the theme in this
show because it's an every page of the
show so what do you really believe what
are you passionate about now what's the
hook in this show well we already know
that so I want to start walking through
this story to see the hook you ever seen
a show called man on the high castle
what's the hook there will our
protagonist succeed in throwing off
Japan and Germany from America making a
murderer what's the hook there will the
villains may actually manage to frame
this guy for murder twice orange is new
Blackwell pipe over ever figure out of
sexuality Breaking Bad it's how far is
Walter gonna go you can see that in this
pilot
it's really really important right so
let's take a look at it and what I
suggest you do is you pull up this pilot
both as a script and as a television
episode and you study it as we go along
and as you do that I'm gonna be breaking
it down so I'll give you a chance now to
buy that class buy that movie from
Amazon there's literally dozens of ways
to get this and then we're gonna do that
we're gonna look at both of those things
so let's start out with Breaking Bad and
as we start out what do we start out
with we start out with a cold open cold
open is just the first five minutes of a
show no titles just right into the show
and structurally we have the first and
the second most important story line in
the entire pilot posed in this cold open
now what is a story line question it is
the central question of your story
what's your story line about what's your
movie about what's your movie what your
television show about what if you had to
ask yourself what is my television show
about what would you say what would your
logline be think of it right now I bet
you have some trouble doing that you get
well it's about it's about a girl who's
an albino and she is being chased I'm
wait a minute hang on no it's about the
corruption of a society wait a minute no
it's about so guys I urge you to try to
logline your story what is the most
important part of your television show
what is the question you want to see
answered in the pilot and maybe
throughout the entire seasons run of
your show okay what is it in mad minutes
we'll Don Draper succeed in not being a
villainous adulterer in his private life
will he let his commercial success heal
him yes that's the a storyline for the
pilot and it's the a storyline for the
entire run of the show for Game of
Thrones the a story log line is which
family will win because we need to unite
everyone in order to fight the white
walkers that's the a story long line and
it's
for the pilot and it's the a story log
line for the entire run of the show yes
all seven or ten or fifteen years
whatever it's going to be so you need to
have in an hour drama at least four
different story lines we call them the
ABCD sometimes you have six more gingy
Cohan and in oranges a new black can
handle twelve but these four story lines
alternate in a very particular pattern
and you need to go to my lecture some
other lecture on university of story
have a television lecture that shows you
how these four story lines alternate in
all hour-long dramas no matter how cool
you are no matter what a hipster you are
David Lynch has to use these patterns
probably unwillingly but every great
creator uses these same patterns of
story why because it's a way to
entertain the audience
television is more complex than movies
we need to have more storylines than we
do in a movie movies usually have only
two story lines television can have up
to ten and an hour drama alternates them
in each act in a very specific way I'm
gonna show you how that's done in
Breaking Bad the a storyline in Breaking
Bad I'm just gonna tell you right now is
this will Walter White become a badass
drug dealer that's it
that's the a question and by the way if
you have a for act chart box which every
television production company uses there
may be five writers like four producers
like six because they can sell more
commercials you will have seven little
boxes and each one of those boxes is a
beat and there are seven in the first
acts seven and the second acts seven in
the third and seven in the fourth
because you have 28 beats in an hour
drama and the a storyline takes up from
14 to 16 of those little boxes the B
story takes up to 6 and those little
boxes maybe 8 the C takes up 3 to 4 and
the D can take up 2 or 3 why because the
a story lines the most important and we
often open and close our acts on our a
stories now guys I know this sounds
complex you can learn it in my lecture
you can learn it somewhere else you
better learn it because that's how
pilots are written so we open up in the
cold open of Breaking Bad
with this RV racing through the desert
with this middle-aged guy wearing
nothing but baggy underwear on Costco
glasses on a gas mask why by the way are
we riveted by this
it's nothing particularly instinct it's
because we're seeing that he drives
badly and he almost crashes over and
over again that's called good news bad
news and a ticking clock is he gonna
crash and these suspense techniques are
used in every single television show and
every single movie that's any good ever
Hitchcock invented a lot of them I just
saw North by Northwest for the first
time the other night I'm sorry I should
have seen it years ago and he uses these
techniques in every scene so Gilligan
does too this RV finally crashes but as
it does we're seeing Walter White in
these baggy pants jumping out of the RV
know what's riveting about this guy he's
dressed in cheap clothes and he's not in
good shape and he's wearing BVDs that
cost $3 why are we interested in him
because he's real an actor given this
role would have worked out for six
months gotten really great abs and lats
and jumped out of the RV hey Here I am
Walter isn't every man and he's got two
bodies in his car and a guy behind the
passenger seat with a gas mask on he
climbs out of the RV he puts his pants
on he grieves his pants and then we hear
what a siren there's a siren the siren
is a ticking clock the cops are coming
so the a story line is will Walter
become a badass drug dealer what's in
the RV two bodies a bunch of chemicals
but now he grabs a video camera and he
tearfully records a farewell to his
family and as he does he says this is
not for the police I'm speaking to my
family now that is the B storyline
remember the a and the B storyline
alternated in the cold open the B
storyline here is will Walt take care of
his family and by speaking to this
camera it looks like he's doing just
that and what does he say I love you
there are things people are gonna tell
me tell you about me they're wrong I'm
not a criminal I wanted to take care of
you
that's the B storyline then the sirens
get louder
Walter takes a gun from his underwear
steps up to the road points the pistol
right at the at the road and stands
there why the siren gets loud boom end
of cold-open
that's a great cliffhanger and it's a
ticking clock and it doesn't get
resolved and we go to the credits so
what have we seen in the cold open a
story B story back to a story that's a
great open
you